let's get more on this we're joined now
by the international security expert dr.
sajan go he'll welcome to you and thanks
joining us on Sky News so still very
much an unfolding situation but from
what we're hearing sounds like a
coordinated attack across the city
unfortunately it does seem to be like
that it seems to be synchronized
involving multiple gunmen designed to
create chaos panic fear across a major
city like Munich they seem to have
targeted very popular places like marine
Clark like that shopping center where
they can try and kill as many people as
possible of course the ideological
motivation still need to be worked out
but this does bring back eerie
similarities to the Mumbai siege
attacking 2008 and the Westgate shopping
mall siege in Nairobi Kenya back in 2013
and you know at the moment of course
this is still an actual situation we
don't know who's responsible but
unfortunately it does have all the
hallmarks doesn't it all the kind of tax
received my ass well one fears that this
is transnational terrorism but this is
mua Shin off the attacks that we have
seen over the last couple of months it
seems to never be ending whether it is
self radicalized individuals or people
inspired people who have been directed
by Isis we are seeing attacks across the
west orlando nice the axe attack in
wolfsburg in germany and now this
incident in munich and i think it's
worth pointing out that the German
authorities had actually issued a
warning on New Year's 2016 to say that
there was a potential imminent threat of
terrorism in Munich so the city itself
has not been immune from the concern
that it could be targeted from terrorism
not been immune from the concerns we
understand by the way from Munich police
they're saying but two eyewitnesses
reporting shootings in three separate
locations including the Olympia shopping
center so are we talking about a city
which was already on high alert the
German authorities have been on high
alert they have been
very concerned ever since the Paris
attacks I love last year that there
could be a potential a plot similar to
that in one of their major city munich
frankfurt of berlin have been in
particular on higher security there's
been greater presence of the police of
armed police especially but
unfortunately you can never stop every
single plot we have to remember that for
the authorities they have to be lucky
all the time the terrorists need to be
lucky just that once and that one can be
quite devastating